stop sweating the small stuff start
looking at all of the negative patterns
that you have created within your mind
the same way we have to look at our food
intake and say all right i'm eating a
lot of crazy crap over here and those
white carbs are not serving me and that
sugar is really not serving me and sort
of do a very good intake and an
inventory of what it is that we're
eating good do an inventory of what
you're thinking what is it that you've
been choosing to think and what is it
that's been holding you back and look
really closely at all the crazy crap
that you've been digesting and choosing
to digest it's the same way that we can
choose to pick up a gross hamburger the
same way we can choose to pick up a
really nasty thought and digest that
thought or try to digest that thought or
try to digest that meal so look at what
you've been choosing for first and
foremost and become super conscious
about what those choices are and how
you've been really polluting your body
and polluting your channel not receiving
love as a result of thinking crap need
motivation watch the top 10 with believe
nation hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
there's something more inside you too
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so get ready to stop sweating
the small stuff find a mentor and
improve your networking skills with
gabby bernstein and my take on her top
10 rules of success to give you the
confidence motivation and belief that
you need enjoy
rule number two find a mentor the first
tip on how to find a mentor is to find
people who have what you want and really
become conscious of all the areas of
life that you see that they are shining
in and become conscious of those areas
and if they have what you want in all of
those areas of life whether it be their
personal life their
career life and the way that they
project themselves out into the world
you can then be clear that that is the
person that you'd want to reach out to
before you start asking people to be
your mentor you want to be very very
conscious of the person that you are
asking and be very clear that this is a
commitment that you want to make as uh
being a mentee is a commitment as well
and then the second step is to become
clear about how you can be of service to
that mentor so
one of the best ways to reach out to
someone that you want to have as a
mentor is to find a way to serve them
and you can look at their career and if
they're someone that's very active on
the internet you can maybe offer to
support them in a publicity way through
social media
if they're a writer maybe you can offer
to edit some of their work if they're a
busy person maybe you can find ways to
run errands for them
so the concept here is to become
conscious of ways that you can serve
them
and that's a really fabulous way to
reach out to a mentor which is to write
a letter or send an email and say hey i
really dig what you're doing i think
you're incredible and i'd like to help
you and if you begin the relationship by
being of service to them you create this
energy around your relationship that
says i really support you and i want to
be a part of your experience and i want
to learn from you
and by serving that person you get to be
near them you get to see how they work
and you get to learn inevitably you
learn a lot and nine times out of ten
those people will really want to serve
you back based on their experience of
your altruism
so i strongly suggest being conscious of
how you can serve them and offering to
be of service
and then the other question is well how
do i how do i find a mentor how do i
even find somebody that inspires me
and so these days with the internet
there's amazing opportunities to use
these resources to look for mentors so
you can obviously use linkedin you can
use facebook even on twitter i have
found people that have inspired me just
by their tweets so start to get your
mentor radar up and and become conscious
of who's out there that's doing great
stuff and who has what you want in all
areas of life rule number three improve
your networking skills i am a networking
junkie i love connecting with people and
i recognize that not everybody is like
that some people are just natural
networkers and we love to walk into a
room and schmoozing a crowd comes
naturally
other people it's completely the
opposite so what i find to be the most
powerful tool to being a great networker
is getting clear about what your
intentions are before you enter into the
networking space
so you may want to say to yourself i
intend to
meet new people tonight or i intend to
get one business card this evening or i
intend to tell one new person about what
i do and keep it simple but but get
clear about that intention i think
oftentimes people enter networking
situations loaded with ideas of all the
things that they should be doing and
need to be doing to create new
relationships and that becomes extremely
overwhelming so if you can keep it
simple and make a clear intention before
you go into a networking environment and
set that intention before you go say a
silent prayer to yourself i intend to do
this
then that intention will easily be
fulfilled rule number four take a fiver
when needed this week's topic came from
a post i put on my facebook fan page
and it was in a moment when i was having
one of those funky days where i felt as
though
i was over tired and a little overworked
and a little overcooked
and rather than get all tripped up about
it and start feeling lower energy and
funky and start making myself crazy
i just remembered a wonderful tool that
i have in my toolbox which is to take a
fiver
and i posted about this on the fan page
because it works for me every time so a
fiber is just taking a little five
minute breathing session just to have
some deep breathing and breathe into our
feelings
a fiver can be to go for a little walk
with a friend which i called my girl
robin i said we gotta go for a little
walk and it helped
uh fiverr could be you know go have a
cup of tea a fiver if you're in the
office could be just step outside of the
office for five minutes walk around the
block and come back
it's like a reboot and sometimes when
we're in this mode of accomplishing so
much and putting so much energy out into
the world and serving so many people
and making money and all the things that
we are doing
we never take a moment to step away and
take care of ourselves and so when we're
in that grind we can be taken over by
the grind
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
rule number five know your intentions
there's a lot of beautiful books out in
the world that talk about manifestation
and talk about co-creating with the
universe and bringing in all the stuff
that we want
and a lot of the
messaging around manifestation is about
getting something about bringing some
some new way into our life so maybe it's
getting that car getting that
relationship getting that job and yes
allowing beautiful miracles to come to
us allowing effects of our intentions to
flow to us is part of the gig but there
is a greater purpose of learning to
co-create learning to practice the power
of manifestation and use the law of
attraction in our life and the primary
tool i'm going to give you today is just
really starting to recognize a a
beautiful concept that my my friend
wayne dyer loves to talk about which is
that our intentions create a reality so
if your intention is to have lots of
money so you can feel better about
yourself you very well may get lots of
money but you won't necessarily enjoy
your life you won't necessarily feel
good about yourself because the money
will not be the service that is going to
bring you that happiness so
recognizing that we can be unapologetic
about whatever it is that we want but we
need to really tune into what is the
intention behind it and if the intention
is is some kind of outside desire that's
some belief system of form that this
thing will make me happy we are wound to
wind up with that thing but still
unhappy so what we need to start to
check into is what is the intention
behind the desire for that outcome
and the intention that's going to lead
us to the greatest happiness is an
intention of service and love
and so when i say service a great
example is i have a new book coming out
in september
and rather than praying and manifesting
and working towards holding visions and
and saying prayers and seeing vision
visualization meditations about seeing
myself on the new york times bestseller
list i've shifted my manifestation and
my process and my and my co-creation to
just seeing this book in the hands of
those who need it and so i'm holding the
vision of millions of people holding
this book in their hands and being
extremely served and healed as a result
of experiencing my work
i know for a fact that that desire and
that intention is fueled with love and
filled with service and as a result
many miracles will occur this this book
is completely hooked up and i already
know the outcome the outcome is is
regardless of whether it's on the new
york times bestseller list or not the
book has already achieved its success
which is to serve
and so when i stay connected to that
greater purpose and recognize that my
intention is to be of service not my
intention is to get on the new york
times bestseller list i can allow that
to occur naturally and more importantly
i can allow the service to come through
rule number six choose positivity start
to recognize
when we can start to change these
negative patterns so it's the same way
you're not gonna necessarily become a
vegan overnight but you can start to
make small right actions towards
powerful changes so start to choose not
to take in those toxic thoughts the same
way when you go on a diet you stop start
choosing not to take in toxic foods you
can begin to choose to stop taking in
toxic thoughts so you can look at your
look at your thought intake and say all
right well when i go to my office i
start binging on fear and it is a
complete nightmare and looking at how
low you feel and how your energy is
weakened and start to get really
connected to the fact that fear intake
is not supporting you and so you may
want to just keep it simple and start
just in the office i choose to go to the
office today and only take in loving
thoughts i'm gonna remove the toxic
thoughts and how do we remove these
thoughts we choose to disengage and
gossip we choose to walk away when
people are really fired up about
negativity we choose to bring a positive
conversation to the environment that
we're in um and we start sweating the
small stuff when someone starts
attacking you for something
maybe rather than fight back you say
okay let's work it out and find ways to
limit the toxicity within your your
mindset and really one step at a time
start to lower that toxic thought intake
rule number seven say thank you the more
we say thank you and the more gratitude
we have the more we will receive and the
more miracles we will witness
when we are in a place of not seeing
those miracles we are in a place of
ignoring the beauty around us we are not
being grateful
so i want you to bring the words thank
you into your vocabulary more this week
so whether it's somebody holding a cab
for you say thank you maybe you wake up
this morning and you feel good just say
thank you
possibly somebody in the office brings
you a cup of tea thank you somebody
opens a lead for you that you might not
have had otherwise make sure you say
thank you and regardless of whether
you're saying thank you to someone or
just acknowledging your gratitude
it's it's the same thing
extremely important for us to become
conscious of all of the guidance that is
around us and to be grateful for that
guidance the more gratitude we have for
that guidance the more that guidance can
show up and the more aware we can be of
it
so like i said if we are not watching
what's happening around us it will
bulldoze past us and we will miss the
miracle
so practice your two favorite words
thank you rule number eight find your
spiritual running buddy growing up
didn't have a lot of close friends and
when i was in high school i felt very
misunderstood and very much like an
outsider and in a lot of cases i felt as
though i never felt connected to a
specific group of people or i never felt
that people were really resonating with
the way that i was thinking and as i've
grown older and become more centered in
my belief systems and become more
connected to my spiritual practice like
a magnet i have attracted most
magnificent spiritual running buddies
and it not only are they specific
individuals who i i work with and and
teach with and for instance some of the
women who i spent yesterday with
teaching at reveal people like megan
waterson and kate northrup and marie
forleo and my sister latham thomas and
elisa viti
and all the amazing sisters who i threw
down with yesterday joanna and dawn all
of them
but it's also all of you it's all of the
people that are on her future.com and
women like masha and danielle and the
women who are all holding up her future
and supporting one another and leading
each other in this spiritual revolution
and we need each other we can't do this
alone and what i found was that as soon
as i began to grow my spiritual practice
like i said it was like a magnet and all
of these amazing women and sisters began
to flood in and men too
people that just resonate with the
energy so i encourage you to open up to
receiving your spiritual running buddies
rule number nine look inward for peace
what i want to really plant the seed
with today and just the simplicity of
what is it all
this concept of having it all is such a
big thing for so many people i want to
have
the love and i want to have the money
and want to have the success and and
we're looking for that freedom and love
in a lot of the wrong places
often we're looking for freedom in the
form of a paycheck or we're looking for
love in the form of another person
we're looking for success in the form of
a credential
and luckily in my case i learned at a
very young age that that wasn't where
happiness love freedom success actually
was it wasn't out there it wasn't in
someone else it wasn't in a business
card it wasn't in a dollar sign it was
something that had to come from within
as a result of activating that happiness
and love and self-worth within we can
allow the universe to reflect that love
and self-worth and success back to us
but the most important message today is
to start looking inward for that piece
and so the first step i want to give you
to learning the tools for having it all
is to start to recognize how you've been
looking for it looking for something to
fulfill you looking for your happiness
and your peace outside of yourself so
just pay attention this week how are you
looking for your serenity and peace and
freedom in money
how are you looking for your safety
security and love in a romantic partner
how are you looking for your self-worth
and success
how are you looking for all of the peace
and love that you are seeking outside of
yourself
and so by first witnessing how you've
projected your internal desires onto an
external circumstance you can begin to
see how that isn't working you can begin
to identify how that outside search is
not the way and rule number 10 the last
24 very special bonus clip is follow the
fun i want to just keep it simple for
you because i think that the key to
exercise is to fall in love with your
exercise for me i was never someone who
could go into that hour-long spin class
like it just wasn't something that was
exciting to me or um for many years
doing vinyasa flow yoga wasn't exciting
to me and not again not putting down any
of these exercise routines but just what
was right for me
i i found like i needed sometimes
something that was more
childlike more playful more fun
and so i was always gravitating towards
exercises like urban rebounding or
getting on those little mini trampolines
and just bouncing
i would be gravitating towards jumping
rope or gravitating towards
rollerblading
kundalini yoga again very fun and
vibrant i have now recently fallen in
love with pilates but the point is it's
not necessarily what the exercise is
it's that i fell in love with the
exercise and by falling in love with the
exercise it became something that i
could just commit to because my body and
my spirit would long for it and so
recognizing the exercises that felt like
a chore versus the exercises that felt
like fun
and so following what was fun has led me
to be an active person
i'm in this three-year journey of trying
to conceive and
really for a year and a half almost two
years i was like in the low of it really
feeling like okay i'm not good enough my
body isn't working how can i make this
happen how can i make this happen right
really pushing and controlling and
trying to eat things and
track my ovulation and all that crap
and then about the fall of 2017 i
started to get into more of a
surrendered state and i started
practicing the methods that i teach in
the book of just really
trusting that there
was
a
higher guidance that i've believed in
for my whole life and relying on that
and that's when things started to get
really wild and synchronistic and so
around the fall of 2017 i was driving in
the countryside where i lived most of
the time and this is where i do the
majority of my manifesting is just
driving in the car looking at the
foliage listening to my mantra music and
i feel so awesome when i'm in that
position and i'm just so grateful in the
moment and i'm driving and i'm driving
i'm like i feel so awesome and so
grateful that i live in this country
town i have all these friends and i
don't have any cell service right now
and i'm so psyched about that and no
one's bothering me and i feel good and
then all of a sudden i felt the presence
of a baby in the back seat
and i was like
wow like deeply moved tears started to
roll down my face i felt so moved
and at that point i heard my intuition
say to me
the baby's coming in march
and i was like and it was so loud like
you know when you hear the voice of your
inspiration you're like that's it okay i
believe and so i started saying to
myself over and over like oh my god
march you know i have to conceive at
this time for the baby to come to work i
saw myself getting a little into it like
too into it and hooked into it so i said
okay listen you know what universe i'm
gonna give this over and if my baby is
indeed coming in march show me a sign
show me lily's to let me know that the
baby's coming in march
and a week later i got a letter in the
mail from a reader and it had this angel
card in it and on the back of it was
this picture of archangel gabriel and
archangel gabriel typically depicted
holding lilies so i was like yo this is
dope and on the back he wrote
i thought that you needed this i was
like thank you good so here i am march
march is coming march is happening and
early march rolled around and i wasn't
pregnant so i was like what the hell and
not only was i devastated once again
another month has gone by i'm not
pregnant but this time i was like i
thought the universe had my back like i
was getting signs like what what's the
uh what's up
so i walked into my husband's office and
i was just hysterically crying so upset
so defeated
and at some my phone was like on the
desk like right here
and all of a sudden my phone started
playing a song
and the song was just repeating
repeating it's like go like you know
when your phone malfunctions you're like
i'm just gonna turn that off i was like
okay i'm just gonna turn out and then i
look at the phone and i start listening
to the lyrics and the lyrics are
way go lily
way go lily and the guy keeps repeating
way go lily and then i look even further
and i look at the name of the song as we
go lily and he keeps repeating lily and
i look even further and the album title
is i see the sign
and where was this playing where what
area of your phone this is just my phone
just turned on oh no that's it you know
it's spirit working through the
technology and so my phone just turned
on it was an album that i'd never heard
i'd never heard the song before it
wasn't in my spotify and it just began
playing now get this
so i get i april rolls around and i'm
pregnant
but then i did the math and i was like
when did i conceive
i conceived the last day of march
so that
synchronicity you know you hear march
you find your signs you feel super
guided
that synchronicity is available to all
of us but it's when it had we have to
get out of that pusher mentality and out
of that controlling behavior to allow
the presence of spirit to work through
us and guide us and or the universe or
whatever you whatever you call it to be
the presence of of of direction
inspiration
to be that guide the voice within us
that believes that we are not allowed to
be happy our card today is speaking to
that
i believe i'm worthy of feeling good i
believe i am worthy of feeling good this
is often something that is a belief
system that sounds really nice
but it's actually far from our reality
because many of us have been brought up
with the belief system that we have to
suffer to succeed that we have to feel
pain to have purpose that we have to
have struggles in order to
feel a sense of serenity in our life
that is all quite backwards
it's when we feel good that we actually
attract more of what we want into our
life but we have to undo the belief
system that says who am i to feel good
who am i to feel great who am i to be
happy that belief system is an ingrained
belief system that can be cultural that
can be something that we learned from
our upbringing it can be something that
we have picked up from this difficult
experience that we're going through
right now with covid when we witness
people suffering we think well how dare
i be happy i would say to you how dare
you not be happy it's your happiness
it's the collective happiness it's the
group collective happiness that raises
the energetic frequency of the world if
we those of us who have moments of
happiness and grace and joy and success
and we don't celebrate them we are doing
the world a disservice we are shutting
down the light we are bringing down the
vibration so we have to when we feel
good we have to reach for more when we
feel good we have to recognize that that
good feeling emotion has momentum it has
power it elevates our children it
elevates our family members it elevates
our friends it elevates strangers on the
street it is your divine duty here on
earth to bring forth that greatness that
goodness that light so when you hear
that voice that says to you you are not
worthy of feeling good i want you to
hear my voice come through and say to
you
who are you not to feel good
this is your divine purpose it is your
mission and it is the way that you heal
and serve you got me
we are more comfortable being
uncomfortable than we are being happy
so when things are good and when we
start to get a sense of feeling good
our ego the voice of fear within us
starts to say hell no too good to be
true and it will find these weird little
corners to pick up problems
we have a fault-finding mindset rather
than a
solution-happiness-oriented mindset so
when that happens the next time you
notice that you're feeling good and all
is well and all of a sudden you're like
but i wasn't nice enough to that person
or my co-workers aren't in a good place
or i didn't do that right i want you to
speak back to that voice i want you to
say thank you for sharing
but i choose happiness instead
thank you for sharing but i don't
believe that voice anymore thank you for
sharing but i'm choosing this moment
give yourself permission in the moment
to speak back to the fault-finding voice
and start to claim the greatness of who
you are that is a pattern because you've
lived your life in a habitual pattern of
seeking problems and finding fault now
we have to redirect and create a new
habit and pattern of grounding you in
the truth of who you are which is
happiness joy peace and
grace sharing that happiness joy and
peace with so much grace
that's what you're here for the
appreciation dissolves the boundary of
fear and appreciation creates more of
what you want so if you've got something
good going on go appreciate it even more
talk about it thrive in it write about
it feel it meditate on the feeling of it
because then you create more of it if
you're in a funk lean on what you
appreciate to get you out of that funk
and make appreciation a daily habit you
know like when you and josh go wake up
in the morning abraham hicks has this
thing called the appreciation game where
you can just play the appreciation game
and just say i appreciate you because
you make me coffee and i appreciate you
because you're a good dancer just really
appreciating your spouse your children
and play that game with your children oh
my goodness start your day going back
and forth with why you appreciate one
another and it immediately just realigns
you puts you into this state where you
feel so good you can't feel bad in the
presence of appreciation and it will
catapult you out of the negativity and
that's what this is all about this is
all about taking these moments and using
these methods and these practices to
consciously and proactively bridge
yourself from that low vibration to a
better feeling emotion and in that
better feeling emotion you become a
super attractor we live in a world that
reinforces a scarcity mentality and that
mentality keeps us in an energy of lack
it keeps us from attracting the career
path that we want the abundance that we
want and allowing us to really live our
purpose
there are six common blocks to abundance
and we all experience them in different
ways
the first block is a lack mentality and
when we have a belief system around lack
we create more lack in our life we all
have stories from our childhood how our
parents experienced abundance or how
they didn't and those stories start to
create a inner dialogue that gets us
into a vibration of feeling like we
don't have enough
and if we feel like we don't have enough
we do a lot of work to try to prove to
the world that we are enough
the second block is the belief system
that there's not enough to go around
we often overwork to try to get it all
we're constantly trying to get get get
because we don't believe that there is
enough it makes us feel like we have to
work so hard to get what we want and
that effort and that anxiety is really
really blocking the natural order which
is the flow abundance
the third block is the block of
comparison
we
literally just turn on our social media
and we're immediately into compare
compare compare
and comparing blocks are attracting
power because it focuses us on what we
don't have rather than feeling good and
feeling faith
the fourth block is the need to win in
the place of having fun because when
we're so focused on winning we lose
track of what it feels like to enjoy the
process and that winning can really get
in our way of allowing
the fifth block is the fear of rejection
when we fear rejection we don't take
action and in effect we create more lack
in our life because we're not actually
trying we're not actually putting out
our desires we're not actually taking
that leap towards what we want
but it's important to understand that
rejection can be protection
when we have some form of rejection show
up in our life it's the universe guiding
us to something better
and the final block is the fear of
judgment
you may be so terrified of being judged
that you don't take that action you
don't show up for your dreams you don't
even contemplate a world where you could
do the thing that you've been dreaming
of you're so afraid of judgment because
you think that other people won't
support you but what's really important
to recognize is that if you're afraid of
what other people think and how they
won't support you it's typically a sign
that you are not supporting yourself
now that you know the six blocks to
abundance i want to give you my methods
for clearing those blocks so that you
can allow abundance to float to you it's
called the universal abundance method
the first step of the universal
abundance method is to protect your
desires so you can stay in alignment
so if you have a really important desire
something that you care about something
that you want to manifest into your life
it's extremely valuable not to talk
about it with anyone who might resist it
step two is to focus on giving rather
than getting
the more we are in that service
mentality
the more positively the universe
responds to us this puts you into an
abundance mentality quickly because the
more you give the more you will receive
and step three is to want more for
others
it is an opportunity for us to see that
we all can succeed we all can have
abundance in our life and the second you
start to intend for others to have more
of what you want for yourself you start
to feel good you start to feel like
you're contributing you start to feel
like you're connecting and you're no
longer comparing or jealous you're no
longer separating yourself from others
redirect your focus from what can i get
to how do i feel and really allow that
feeling of abundance to propel you
forward and create momentum and allow
the universe to bring to you all that
you desire and then the next question i
have for you is when you're thinking
about manifestation and calling in new
things are some of you manic manifesting
so this is really important
some of you those folks who are like
i've got the list i've got the vision
board i've said it a thousand times i
told all my friends i want him i know
exactly what he looks like and i feel
like he's with me and we're walking down
the street together holding hands
you know who you are
you know who you are right you know
exactly who you are
look there's nothing wrong with being
clear
there's nothing wrong with being clear
but more importantly i want you to be
clear about how you want to feel and i
want you to just feel it
it's not about having the vision board
that's perfect it's not about having the
most amazing list you can do all that
work you can get clear you can be and if
anyone has a note of vision board it's a
beautiful board where you put all of
your images of what you want and plenty
of people spend a lot of time on that
board but they don't get into the energy
of what it feels like
and so they spend a lot of time with the
list they spend a lot of time with the
board and they spend a lot of time
talking about it but they don't assume
the energy of what it feels like to be
in that manifestation now
assuming the energy of what it felt like
to pop off all your tops really helped
me call in something that will help me
do it
assuming that energy just brought me
into a state of being you are already
there sister you are already doing this
exactly as you are on your video blogs
in your lectures on twitter and facebook
you are already there and you want more
but you are already there
so acknowledging and accepting that i'm
already in the place that i am even
though i want it to be more i am already
there
so if you want a romantic partner
make sure you have a real hot romance
with yourself
if you want more money
make sure you have a real good
relationship with the money you
currently have
if you want a new job make sure you have
a real good relationship with the job
you have today
everybody get that people think oh well
if i appreciate my job that i have now
then i'll only stay there no absolutely
not if you appreciate the job that you
have now then you show up to that job
with grace
you show up to that job with a good
attitude you show up that job with a
better approach you show up to that job
with more energy that job begins to
thank you that job says wait maybe
there's another job for you that job
then says here you're promoted here's
some more money have a great life
you
create your reality your intentions
create your reality so if you are
constantly in a place of thinking i hate
this i hate this i hate this you are
serving that
everybody's with me now i know you are
so rather than focusing on that manic
manifesting first and foremost get
honest if you are one of them if you are
please raise your hands now manic
manifesters just get honest people
get your hands up
manic manifesto so you're reading the
books you're doing the work you think
you think you think but your energy
what's your energy like scream it to me
what's your energy like
frantic
what was that
when you're saying when got it yes okay
what is your energy saying when your
energy is needy right it's controlling
it's manipulative
it's frightened
it's chaotic
what does that girl look like on a date
[Music]
so what is your energy doing how is your
manic manifesting affecting your genuine
manifestation
so i want you to get clear about that
and then the next piece here is just to
become super conscious and maybe you
take yourself for the next 30 days
where you can use that exercise in my
inbox where you put the little rubber
band around your wrist and you snap the
rubber band every time you catch
yourself talking about lack or you catch
yourself you know avoiding your finances
or you catch yourself eating the
hamburger or you catch yourself manic
manifesting just check yourself before
you wreck yourself
and sl and snap
your wrist right take that little
everybody got that
you hear yourself you're in the
conversation with your girlfriend and
you're like oh my god i can't get it i
don't know what's going on the man won't
call me back i can't kill myself oh my
god and then all of a sudden instead of
continuing
snap the rubber band
i say i forgive myself
for my lack mentality i forgive myself
for my fear i choose to see this
differently
that's it
you don't need to figure out what to see
differently you just need to say i
choose to see this differently and you
will be given all you need to see
something different i've been
really working on getting honest and
telling the truth and being forthcoming
about how i'm feeling i know this is
something that can be very squirrely for
people we can get really hung up about
actually saying how you feel and telling
the truth but when we don't tell the
truth we actually stifle our energy we
create toxic relationships we carry
resentments and it builds up and builds
up and builds up so i've gotten to the
practice of just just radically telling
the truth wherever i am however i need
to be authentic and truthful about what
i'm feeling but i have a few steps that
i think are important that you need to
take in before you actually
give that truth over because if you
share your truth without cleaning up
your side of the street it'll feel like
an attack it'll feel like judgment so
the process of telling the truth is
quite simple
first take a look at your side of the
street look at what's up for you if you
feel called to get honest with somebody
what is it within you that's feeling
triggered what is it that's that's
feeling activated and do whatever you
need to do to clear that whether it be
forgiving yourself forgiving the other
person saying prayers for that other
person sending loving energy to that
other person and clean up the energy
before you bring over the truth because
you don't want to show up with this
nasty attitude because your truth won't
be heard you need to bring your truth
with a lot of light so that they can see
their light reflected back to them
so the process is really simple look at
your side of the street before you show
up and tell the truth and then be
prepared to get honest from a place of
love if you can tell the truth from a
place of love then you will be heard and
that's when you feel healed and that's
when a healing can be offered up to the
relationship but as long as you're
telling the truth from a place of
negativity or judgment it will not be
heard and it won't work i learned this
the hard way unfortunately but the
experience has given me this great
opportunity to learn how to tell the
truth with grace and power
the benefit of telling the truth is that
you start to feel like you're taking
care of yourself you start to feel like
you're owning your voice you're owning
your needs you're protecting yourself
when you need to protect yourself and
you're sticking up for what your values
are no matter what and you're also just
you know really getting clear about what
your boundaries may be within certain
relationships and so sometimes people
may not like your truth but you could
always trust that if you're sharing your
truth from a place of love you will be
heard even if they get defensive even if
they get upset that your loving presence
is enough to allow that truth to come
through in a very authentic way the
other part that may be very helpful is
once you've told your truth give the
person their opportunity to tell their
own hold that space for them to say how
they feel there's always two sides to
every story so speak up and then allow
the other person to speak up clearing
that space for the truth to unfold and
trusting that the truth will totally set
you free my mom has always said this to
me for my entire life the truth will set
you free the truth will set you free
and i believe that we all want freedom
we want freedom from resentment freedom
from anxiety freedom from fear and that
freedom is available as we start to open
up to the truth within us i went on my
instagram and i was like how many of you
i did a
poll and i said how many of you are
blocking you're manifesting and 96
percent said yes
yeah and then and there's and i call it
out i caught the ways that we block and
i and this whole book is methods for
unblocking and and the thing is is that
you know the thing that's most important
is if to trust that if you're watching
this right now that you are in in fact
being guided so even if you don't feel
that guidance you can't hear that
inspiration there's no way that you
would have listened to this specific
podcast in this specific moment if you
were not indeed being guided
okay so just take that in fully and
completely and then your next step is to
recognize the guidance and then follow
the guidance you receive whether it's
read this book or not this book maybe
another book maybe after this podcast
you're led to another author on your
podcast and then that's the book that
you need or that's the the therapist
that you need to find it doesn't have to
be me but but but stay open and when
when you have an intuition to listen to
a podcaster it's when you're feeling
free and you make a decision to do
something it's when you're in a place of
of of
you know no agenda just a place of joy
inspiration relaxation and you start to
listen to something or a guy just that's
that's when you're really listening
that's when you're really receiving
guidance so i think anyone that's
listening to you is listening but they
just may not realize it everyone that's
walking through this this world every
human being
they may not have had to have trauma
like we've had but they're walking
through life
feeling
unsafe
they may not have had sexual abuse or a
father that abandoned them but maybe
their teacher told them they were stupid
or maybe
they you know they like
got lost one day in the parking lot when
they were a kid and didn't find their
mom it doesn't these subtle moments are
as of course in miracles says the
moments that we detour into fear they
call it the descent from magnitude into
littleness and we then create this form
of ego which is a separate mind separate
from god separate from love separate
from that freedom and it builds up a
pretense around us i mean i've been
living in it right now i'm watching a 10
month old child so free of ego so free
of fear and i'm so conscious of every
moment and so conscious of not you know
being on my phone when i'm with him
because i don't want to create look i'm
going to create those moments he's going
to have he's a human having a human
experience but i want to hold him in the
preciousness of this god-like state as
long as possible right but that's not
how people's parents are right
yeah that's how we grew up right
we grew up we all grow up in this world
where there's just so each moment is an
opportunity to detour into fear and then
we create a world of
fear-based perceptions
and so what we must do to live and
thrive and feel good is undo those
fear-based perceptions and i believe
through a spiritual path or through
maybe a therapeutic i think spirit's in
all of it whether you realize it or not
but to make a commitment to feel better
means that you're committed to returning
to god
or love or word you know spiritual
universe
as i commit to happiness fully
exactly what i need is coming towards me
because i become a magnet i become an
energy field that is so magnetizing that
is so excited that so inspired
that other people want to support and
work with that energy and so when we
dwell in the energy of joy and happiness
we become a magnet for that which we
desire so my hope for you all is to
start to think about the things that you
want to succeed in whether it's
succeeding in romantic relationships or
succeeding in your career or succeeding
in your health goals and make a
commitment today to bring more joy
to that area of your life rather than
seeing it as a struggle rather than
pushing forward with all this angst and
negativity and neediness and control
just bring joy to it
your successes will come when you commit
to joy when you commit to happiness so
find more joy in that physical exercise
i've been going to soul cycle i
absolutely love it it's so joyful for me
and that's helping me raise my butt
because that was one of my goals and
success and and then we have these
moments where we want to really bring
joy into our career well if you're
having a hard time in the office just
find ways to have more fun and as we
start to elevate that presence of joy we
will begin to magnetize the successes in
our life and so take this very seriously
bring this practice into your day-to-day
experiences and make joy and happiness
your number one priority and recognize
how your successes will be brought to
you in a form far greater than you could
ever imagine when your primary focus is
happiness i think that
we all have uh in our own ways
unresolved wounds from
attachment breach from childhood
experiences from feelings of being
unlovable and not good enough
they will continue to show up for us as
somatic experiences they'll show up in
our lives as gut conditions as
men as
as anxiety disorders they may show up as
insomnia they may show up as back pain
they will show up until you show up for
them in my life as a
human but also as a spiritual personal
growth teacher i have been in the
devotional commitment of showing up for
my
my
wounded part so that i can step into the
resourced
healthy whole
part of who i am
the journey i've been on is nothing
short of a miracle i've i as you
mentioned earlier i was a drug addict in
my 20s
got sober at 25 just through my own
desire to be clean
then in my mid-30s i remembered i
remembered a dissociated traumatic event
from my childhood
that really put me on the path of
understanding why i used in the first
place to really understand why i was a
drug addict
and then really made the devotional
commitment to go further than my
spiritual practice and really start to
develop a therapeutic many therapeutic
practices for
helping myself get back to a healthy
baseline
and for restoring my nervous system and
grounding my energy so that i can be
where i am today lisa which is so
happy
so at ease so healthy and well and i i
wouldn't be able to be in this place now
if i hadn't had the opportunity to
do all the big lifting and heavy lifting
that i experienced before so i'm
grateful for the tough stuff because
it's revealed the great stuff now not
only do i talk about spirit guides and
angels and deceased family members but i
also talk about your higher self so if
this is too woo-woo for you
start to tap into what is the voice of
my higher self gotcha right that voice
of my inner guidance system and that
wisdom that i believe in is my is my
true nature right
but i i personally gabby bernstein i
believe that i that we all have
guides ancestors family members teachers
beings of light beings energy beings
that are supporting us in a in a form
that is is
able to step in able to channel through
us when we write books able to to be
there in those darkest moments pick us
up off the floor uh and and and hold us
in in discomfort and guide us to
business opportunities or babies or
whatever it is that we're looking for
and it's always available to us that
guidance but we just we cut it off we
block it
why do we block the guidance fear is the
reason we block it fear
it's not even fear it's that false-based
perception that we've built up around
ourselves from those traumatic events
right so we have these traumatic events
early in life and they continue to build
and build and build we build up a world
of false perceptions i am this body i am
gabby bernstein i am lewis howe i've got
the school of great people
i can't trust people we we create these
right beliefs and you believe you're
separate from others you believe you're
you're better than or less than or not
good enough and all those stories all
those those false pretenses are what
what many spiritual
practices called the ego right and that
fear-based perception of yourself is
misaligned with with with god with love
with spirit with angels with guides and
so this book is all about how to get
back into alignment so that you can hear
that guidance and receive that guidance
and be a
channel for inspiration and when you
when you clear and undo those patterns
of fear and start to claim the pattern
of love that's when you are
hooked up super attractor
unstoppable unstoppable invisible doors
open for you it doesn't matter how low
you are when you're starting this you
will go way further than you could
possibly have imagined there's no such
thing as a mistake everything happens in
divine order i am being guided to learn
and grow here we go people
when we look at the situations in our
life from a place of regret
we ultimately miss the opportunity for
growth we miss the opportunity to see
what could have been beneath that
discomfort we miss the opportunity to
acknowledge and recognize that every
experience in our life is not an
accident it doesn't happen by accident
it happens in a divine order and when we
live and lead and show up for our life
grounded in that belief system
then we can face our most
difficult moments
with a
sense of purpose and power
and we can show up for those moments
with a opportunity to grow focusing on
the opportunity to grow focusing on the
opportunity for a shift for strength for
spiritual awakening for a new way of
being and a new perception of our lives
so that's a lot i know that's a lot i
know that when something really bad
happens like what we've been
experiencing recently in the world what
we experienced in the united states last
week when we experienced something like
a pandemic we don't want to see the
spiritual assignment we don't want to
see that this is not a mistake
but typically when difficult things
happen they are revealing what needs to
be healed these uncomfortable moments
whether they be global or they be
personal are revealing what we have to
heal whether we have to heal it on an
individual level which is where it
begins and what we have to heal on a
global perspective on a global level so
showing up to all these uncomfortable
moments and recognizing them that they
are not a mistake that they are
happening in a divine order and it's our
opportunity to perceive these situations
from the lens of what can i learn from
this how can i grow from this how can i
shift from this how can i lean towards
more love how can i lean towards more
joy how can i lean into the lesson
rather than the problem the solution
rather than seeking all of the faults
and and looking for all of the problems
i now have deep appreciation for that
dark hole i was in six months ago
because it's giving me an opportunity to
sit here with you today and hopefully
save some lives yeah if there's a mother
out there that's watching and she's
having suicidal thoughts or she's having
panic attacks or she's having insomnia
that she can now go and talk to her ob
gyn or her psychiatrist i am deeply
grateful for for everything i've been
through through my addiction recovery
from my trauma healing through physical
things that i've talked about publicly
because they've given me a greater
level of compassion
for what people for the human condition
and a greater much greater opportunity
to speak and teach from a place of
authenticity so that's my my
appreciation for what has been and i
think if we start to look at the
difficult times in our lives and
appreciate them and also recognize them
as a learning device saying okay thank
you
alcoholism or thank you you know fear or
thank you drama in my life right now
because you're revealing to me
what i still need to heal when you fully
accept that you are here to be great
when you fully accept that you are here
to be happy when you fully accept that
you are here to receive when you fully
accept that you can have
the peace and the serenity and the joy
and the wisdom and the purpose and the
intention that you intend to bring to
the world and that it is all available
to you
that's when life gets very groovy
and so my hope and my intention for
today
is to wake you up to that presence
i more importantly give you a really
great new york city kick in the ass that
says not only i'm awake to it not only
do i believe in it
but i am committed to it
i am unapologetic about my capacity to
be great i am unapologetic about my
capacity to heal i am unapologetic about
my capacity to see beyond my physical
sight i am unapologetic about my
capacity to shine
as bright as i can shine because i trust
and i know that when i shine bright i
give others permission to do the same
and in my glow they wake up to
and that is why we're here you might
agree with me on this like i can in one
hour i can do more than the average
person can do in a day or two days okay
and that's because i do things from
inspiration
and so when you're inspired you're in
spirit and you are expanding time you're
given more energy and
you just can get you know every things
download fast i get a call from my one
of my team members and she's like uh
don't go on facebook i was like what
she's like
there's a whole
person's facebook page and they're
railing on you and they're going off
about you
and
maybe like 30 people had chimed in being
like oh you hate gaby brizzy thank god
somebody's talking about it
just like you know going after me yeah
and
well 30 people is a small number in the
grand scheme of the universe this feels
really overwhelming and and even one
person hating you on the internet can
can shake you to your core
so i
lo i just i do what anyone would do in
that moment and i start to go down that
hole of of shame and upset and what did
i do wrong and how could i have
triggered these people in this way and
what you know what is my part and just
getting so hooked into it even though
you know a lot of what was being said
was being said without any information
right uh you know but regardless i
didn't even need to dig into it to feel
the feelings of discomfort and i was
getting really really hung up about it
really hung up about it and took you
know probably it was about a full day of
just like
being down and bummed out and i remember
i was watching television with my
husband at night i was staring at my
phone just being like did more people
weigh in like what's happening and he
looked at me he's like what is going on
what you can't even be present with me
in this room why are you so stuck in
this i was like it feels so horrible to
be
you know pounded on on the internet and
i'm so upset about it and he said listen
you've got it all wrong girl this is how
my husband became a guru he said
you are focusing all your energy on
these 30 people who are hating you but
you have thousands of people on your dm
on instagram that are trying to send you
love that are asking you questions that
want your support and you don't even
know how to find your dm
you and me were in the same boat for a
long time
yeah yeah and he's like you don't even
know how to find it he's like let me
show you how to find your dm and focus
on the people that need you not on these
people that are hating on you so
i spend the next four days just dming dm
i mean dm like i went on my instagram i
was like yo who wants to dm like let's
talk
and so i'm just like in it and i'm just
feeling so like within 48 hours i was
just like so transformed by just being
in the service of others and connecting
to the people that really wanted to to
hear from me and wanted my support and
what happened that was so so
transformational was i woke up one
morning a few days into this and i woke
up at like 5 a.m and i was i was upset
by
the still a little upset but i thought
came right back in oh there they are why
are they talking about me of course and
in that moment i was like okay zach said
get on dm so i get back on my dm and i
start dming and i see this girl and
she's talking to me and she's saying you
know listen i um was sober for two years
i just went out i feel like i'm i want
to commit suicide right now i started
dming with her within the hour i'm on
the phone with her
and
that day she made a commitment to go
back to recovery
so i have
deep gratitude for those haters because
those haters gave me this beautiful
opportunity of service to somebody and
potentially save her life
and and and and also just get over it
many of us have issues with productivity
maybe we are overly productive but we're
feeling burnt out all the time or we're
not productive at all because we don't
know where to start
i found personally being in business for
myself for the last 20 years that i have
been a little overly productive i almost
did too much and i was constantly
multitasking and making things happen
and just moving so fast that ultimately
i really burnt out and i started feeling
brain fog i was feeling disoriented i
couldn't focus i was feeling like even
though i for so many years was priding
myself on the fact that i could get so
much done at one time i actually don't
think i was being nearly as productive
as i could have been
so i hit a bottom recently with this
productivity overload and i realized
that i had to change my patterns i had
to change my ways i was then blessed i
said a prayer i said i need some help
with my brain fog and i need some help
with my productivity issue and i that
day got an email from the dr oz show
asking me to come on and do a segment
with
this lovely author and dr dr mike dao
and me and mike had been in touch many
years
for many years just because he hadn't
been an author we were published by the
same publishers and mike had written a
book about brain fog so that day i'm
like thank you universe you're giving me
exactly what i need i go on dr oz with
mike and i'm backstage with him and i'm
like listen i'm feeling so
chaotic and i'm multitasking so much and
my i feel like i've got brain fog and
i'm forgetting things and he looked at
me says how much are you doing at one
time and i said oh mike i'm doing a
million things at once i have a thousand
tabs up on my screen and he's like these
are big brain no-no's and they're also
productivity no-no's is what he said
because he said that the more i try to
do and the more i try to multitask the
less i'm actually getting done so he
gave me a tip that i want to share with
you that has changed everything for me
and his suggestion was to just do five
things a day
to make a list of the five most
important things that i need to do that
day and not do number two until i've
completed number one and then once i
complete number one move on to number
two then on to number three and if i
don't get through all five in one day
i'll just pick up the fifth the next day
or wherever i left off i'll pick up the
next day
and to really stick to that list and not
move back and forth and not try to make
a million other things added on to that
list and just be really committed to
that five task list
i did it i started to just be very clear
about the five things i was doing in a
day i told my team i made a a list in my
base camp which is where we keep all of
our notes and i made it really clear to
myself these are the only five things
i'm doing throughout the day
as a result of making it super clear and
conscious to myself that i was only
going to do five things i have been more
productive i have created more have been
more intuitive i have been more inspired
and i've been more creative everyone has
unresolved areas where they are out of
alignment due to their upbringing their
belief systems from childhood
experiential belief systems whatever has
been imprinted
so some people might be health some
people might be sex some people it might
be money some people it might be their
worth some people might be all of the
above whatever we've all got it we've
all got an area or many where we are
misaligned with
the feeling of love and abundance and
and grace
that's normal that's natural that's
where it's at and just because you fall
into those belief systems and feel into
that frequency from time to time doesn't
mean that you are doing anything wrong
it's that you are your awareness of it
is actually major okay
so
the undoing of the lac mentality is a
journey of
clearing
the belief systems from a experiential
time in your life right that happens
once again through books like the
universe has your back so fantastic that
you're doing that transform fear to
faith
excellent work
it comes through therapeutic practices
like we've been talking about today it
comes through mental reconditioning and
here's the good news we all have these
conditioned neural pathways
from the experiences that we've had as
children particularly young childhood
experiences but the good news is thanks
to neural plasticity our brain actually
can
change
our brain can reorganize our brain can
become new our fight flight responses
can subside our ptsd can dissolve our
lack mentality can turn into an
abundance mentality we our brain has the
power to change and so much of that
change happens with the repetition of
new behavior so
one thing that you can do simply in this
moment is to notice
when you are in that lac mentality
notice how it makes you feel
forgive the thought
and choose again
and this is a method i've shared over
and over and over again on this show the
choose again method because
yes i could say to all of you go do 10
years of therapy which everyone i hope
will have the opportunity to do whatever
that form that comes but
what you can do for yourself you're here
for self-help you're here for gabby to
tell me how i can serve myself you can
be in the proactive development of new
thought patterns that feel better
not fat patterns that you don't believe
in but thought patterns that make you
feel better
so when you notice that lack story show
up step one notice the thought and how
it makes you feel step two forgive
yourself for having the thought it's
very simple up there's my childhood
story there's my parents lack story
again up there it is again all right i
forgive myself just showed up again
because that forgiveness will dissolve
that guilt and tension and fear that
you're manifesting it all that crap
right
third step
choose the next best feeling thought
choose the thought of you know what i
just forgave myself for that thought so
i'm dissolving it in this moment i
actually am listening to the universe
has your back and it's so supportive
then i can actually go and listen to
super attractor so you can go from
thought to thought to thought to reach
for the next best feeling thought
so
your willingness to face the slack
mentality is already activating
abundance within you
right and especially if you're feeling
afraid that you're manifesting things
because you're having the thoughts then
just forgive the thoughts because or
forgive yourself for having the thought
because the moment that you say oh i
forgive myself for that thought or i
forgive that thought
it doesn't have power over you anymore
because you've recognized i am not that
thought it's just a thought that i keep
thinking i am not that belief it's just
a thought that i keep thinking
[Music]
because you made it this far in a video
i want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but you
are different you are special believe
nation you made it here all the way to
the end and i love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments below on this video
i will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because
you are awesome to watch my recent 101
sit down with gabby bernstein check the
video right there next to me i think
you'll love it continue to believe and
i'll see you there trauma is very
delicate and we all have it you rip off
the band-aid too fast
you'll get blown out
it'll be too too scary at once we all
have the capacity to be of service to
others